we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p got a very
nice voicemail from a teacher over the
weekend take a listen to this
hey david this is tim from Bloomsburg
Pennsylvania I'm a 25 year old middle
school teacher and I just made my first
patreon pledge yes as this show
emphasizes critical thinking and media
literacy something we desperately need
in our classrooms around the country
thank you keep up the great work and
I'll be a supporter for years to come
thank you so much Pat and David of
course all right
very very nice voicemail the miniseries
are going really well the critical
thinking miniseries was extraordinarily
well received the pseudo-science
miniseries so far is well received
although we actually do have in our
audience and it is a little bit
depressing to me some pseudo science
believers who have surfaced and started
to say no psychics are real astrology is
real etc that's a little bit
disappointing to me but overall the
pseudoscience miniseries is being but
very well received and we're gonna keep
doing it we're gonna keep doing it and I
appreciate the support I guess we could
have anticipated that just because many
of these pseudo Sciences are widespread
yeah they're among our audience of
course but around among the general
public generally some people are gonna
believe in astrology other people are
gonna believe in chiropractic medicine
sure the whole game whoa pet that was
now as a pet that just stepped in it
shots fired across the bow yeah just
wait pat may not be able to survive this
week on the David Pakman show after
mentioning chiropractic okay on the
bonus show today
we will not be talking about
chiropractic arts or Sciences depending
on your perspective on that we will be
talking about what's going on
with the Thai cave rescue and we will
talk about why does that get so much
attention when the thousands of African
children dying every day of hunger and
get almost no attention in Western media
I know it's cliche people are gonna hear
me say that and they'll say David again
with the African children dying of
hunger we shouldn't care about the
African children but I think it actually
illuminates some very interesting media
biases that we should all be aware of we
will also talk about Filipino president
Rodrigo Duterte saying he will quit his
job as president if somebody can prove
God exists via a selfie a selfie would
be the vessel through
which he would want that proven we will
also report to you about ID Adam the man
who questioned a black woman's right to
use a pool he has lost his job after
what is widely agreed to be although not
by everybody not by maybe the race
realists but it's mostly consensus that
his questioning of a black woman's right
to use a pool was racially motivated we
will talk about those three stories and
more on today's bonus show
don't miss the bonus show the bonus show
at this point is it's exciting and
titillating to members and patrons of
all ages become a member at WWJ join
pakman.com or become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
quite a mouthful we'll talk to you on
the bonus show